You know that song you hear every New Year's Eve?
The one no one ever seems to get the words right?
"For Old Aunt of Mine", "For Old Ang Zing", "Please Hold My Sign."
Well, actually the words are really "For Auld Lang Syne."
We sing it every year, but do you know what it really means?
"For Auld Lang Syne" is a Scottish folk song originally transcribed by Robert Burns in the 1700s.
Now, a good translation for the phrase "Auld Lang Syne" means "Times Gone By."
It's sung as a remembrance of the past as we look towards a bright, new tomorrow.
Happy New Year!
So, at the end of the night, when you warm up your vocal cords to belt out this song,...
...think of your friends, your family and acquaintances,...
...let go of the bad and be thankful for the people who've touched your life and made it better.
So, grab a hand and raise a glass for "Auld Lang Syne."